california is ready to drop most of its
coronavirus restrictions
social distancing and capacity limits
will be phased out when the state
officially reopens
on june 15th new cases were down 19
across the country this week compared to
last
july with just shy of half the country
receiving
at least one dose of the coronavirus
vaccine
this is 38 percent of americans are now
fully vaccinated but the pace of
vaccinations is slipping
showing a steady decline in recent weeks
it's leading states even the federal
government to get creative in hopes of
encouraging more people to get
vaccinated michael george
is here with more michael good morning
dana good morning to meet the
president's goal of a nation
70 percent vaccinated by july 4th that's
a 160 million adults
another 22 million people need to get
their shots so from coast to coast
many are pulling out all the stops
lottery tickets for the vaccinated
oregon's governor went
all in yesterday there will be one
one million dollar winner for residents
18
and over who've received at least one
dose of their vaccine by june
27th new york's governor upped the ante
you get a vaccination and you get a
lottery ticket for the 5 million dollar
mega multiplier new york state lottery
pick your incentive how about lakers
basketball tickets
the white house is into online dating
promoting sites featuring vaccination
badges for those
looking for love people who display
their vaccination
status are 14 percent more likely to get
a match
we have finally found the one thing that
makes us all more attractive
a vaccination there's some indication
that younger people could be key
in helping meet the president's 70
percent july 4th goal
indiana university and the university of
virginia yesterday joined other big
league schools
in mandating only vaccinated staff
faculty and students can return
in the fall i do think it's a great idea
because we all want to get back to
normal and i think that's
one of the best ways to do it all this
comes as more places drop
mask requirements but the cdc has a new
study of schools
showing how important masks still are
the report released
yesterday found covid19 infections were
37 percent
lower in schools that require teachers
and staff members to use
masks
even as some continue protesting over
masks
and safety and the vaccine numbers
really vary state by state
maine leads the nation with half its
population vaccinated but if you look at
places like mississippi or alabama
they're closer to 25 percent michelle
all right thank you michael the